hello everyone and welcome to today's
webinar Clini max prodigy adherent cell
culture systems automated large-scale
and GMP compliant manufacturing of
various stem cells and their derivatives
I am the shell action of blabbers and
I'll be your moderator for today's event
today's educational web seminar is
presented by labyrinth and brought to
you by Milton biotech to learn more
about our sponsor please visit no WWLP
HS comm now let's get started before we
do I would like to remind everyone that
this event is interactive we encourage
you to participate by submitting as many
questions as you want and any time you
want during the presentation to do so
simply type them into the ask a question
box and click send answer as many
questions as we have time for at the end
of the presentation if you have trouble
seeing or hearing the presentation but
on the support tab found at the top
right of the presentation window or
report your problem by clicking on the
ask question box located on the far left
of your screen this presentation is
educational and best offers continuing
education credits please could click on
the continuing education credits tab
located at the top right of the
presentation window and follow the
process to obtain your credits
I now present today's speakers Sebastian
Noble the manager of research and
development at Milton biotech and Chao
Shang the product manager of
regenerative medicine at Milton biotech
for the complete biographies on our
speakers please visit the biography tab
at the top of the screen our speakers
will now begin their presentations
Oh welcome to our presentation so we are
actually very glad that we have this
great opportunity to present you our
latest technologies for automated GMP
compliant and scalable stem cell
manufacturing my name is Chow Chang I'm
the product manager for regenerative
medicine portfolio at Newton Ebell Tech
and I hope that you will find our
presentation helpful for your project
so first this is our presentation
disclaimer
then at first I will
show you a few key facts about mutiny
biotech
our company was founded in 1989 and
after 30 years grows today the Milton
family holds 2,500 members from 44
different nations were committed to
empowering stems sent if ik discovery
and also impacting human lives every
year the more than 55,000 cell therapy
procedures are performed using our
products and more than 2,500 patients
are treated with the cellular products
using our technologies
in the last 30 years we have gained
extensive experiences in cell
manufacturing we open our GMP
manufacturing facility in petrol Germany
in 2002 and in 2012 we launched the
climax strategy as the next generation
platform for commercialized cell
manufacturing based on the climax
prodigy platform in 2016 we released our
TSL transaction system for car diesel
manufacturing and in 2017 we open our
Milton about a Excel factory as a grand
champ isn't cell manufacturing facility
today there are more than 15,000 product
in our portfolio supporting sentence and
the patience from bench top to bedside
in this presentation we will focus on
the self processing part especially our
cutting-edge technology for automated
and scalable stem cell manufacturing
sitting next to me is dr. Sebastian
noble project leader of our brand-new
climax prodigy adhere in cell culture
system this automated and closed the
system is dedicated to addressing the
challenges in GMP compliant and
large-scale manufacturing of various
that here in cell types such as
mesenchymal stem cells proponents
themselves and their derivatives
Sebastian will share with you our
solutions to automate to standardize and
to scale up the manufacturing processes
and at the same time to reduce the
production costs and make cellular
products more affordable for patients
more detailed information about the
climax prodigy adhere in the cell
culture system can also be found in the
links to the melt new website without
further ado so now I would like to give
the time to Sebastian
you for the nice introduction and also
welcome to our talk from my side as you
might know GMP manufacturing of a
cellular product is a very complex
endeavor as depicted in the simplified
process scheme it involves a multitude
of devices and sophisticated clean room
facilities manual handling steps and
skilled personnel how to make a cell a
product and scalable in the fordable
manner one of the biggest challenges of
GMP cell manufacturing is the complexity
and this significantly drives up the
costs and at the same time it limits the
manufacturing scale and consistency but
how to make this very complex our
manufacturing processes standardized
scalable but at the same time affordable
for patients
our solution is to integrate all these
various steps into one automated device
and here comes our clinics project
platform designed for complex cell
product manufacturing
I would briefly like to go through the
cleanness prodigy adherent cell culture
system with you including the hardware
and software
let's have a closer look at the hardware
this is the functionally integrated and
clothes clean MX prodigy instrument
together with a disposable single-use
tubing set and other accessories the
prodigy system allows automated side
processing from starting materials to
final products upon your request it can
perform sample preparation density
gradient centrifugation cell washing
medium change magnetic cell separation
cell stimulation genetic modification
but also final product formulation now
what are the main features of the closed
system we use the rio singer your
Stubing sets in which all process take
place so cells are never in contact with
the device itself at any time so we
provide single use sterile filters at
the input ports and the starting
material is connected via steer our
docking buffin media bags can be steerer
welded on and off during the process and
the final product is retrieved by
sterile unwilling of the target cell bag
QC sample pouches are also provided and
part of the chewing set and can be
retrieved during the process for improv
controls cell cultivation can be
performed in the cell tree centric art
unit and external circuitry vessels
there is a clean MX prodigy chamber that
lies inside of the center cut unit or
so-called CCU the CCU is the heart for
cell manufacturing it supports automated
adherent and non-apparent circuit
evasion
and in this chamber there is a
temperature control you have co2 and air
and m2 control and you can visually
examinate the cell through a microscope
additionally the external circuit vessel
allows scalable manufacturing since they
can be connected to the tubing set via
steerer welding and enlarge the surface
that is available
key piece of equipment is the tubing set
the TS 7:30 has been specifically
designed for a terror cell culture
system to meet the requirements for cell
manufacturing in terms of handling and
usability this new GMP team set provides
additional tubing connections and
increased tubing length to allow
comfortable operator interaction during
the process that is for instance when
connecting or disconnecting bags with
this I'd like to shift your attention to
the software application to the right
you see a menu screen that gives an
indication of the different modules that
we provide for manufacturing of unit
cell types like pre report themselves
neural cells carry myocytes and MSC we
have developed this specific new
software we call it the Terran cell
culture system the biggest challenge
here is that there are so many different
types of adherent cells we really have
to make sure that our system is flexible
enough to meet all these demands that is
why we modular modularized individual
cell culture stairs in this system for
example in the starting screen you can
find modules like density gradient
centrifugation coating media change
culture and other relevant steps and
their adherence our culture system
allows free combination of different
modules thus offers a high degree of
flexibility for various cell culture
applications coming back to the process
scheme that are introduced to you
earlier you may notice that all process
steps are reflected by the different
modules in the acc system and within
these modules you can choose between the
different cultivation vessels the CCU or
ecv and you can also setup important
cultivation parameters upon your request
for example in the coding module you can
set up the coding temperature the coding
time and coding solution volume
according to your manual protocol you
will have an overview in the summary
page and you can also reset if you
decide to change any parameters the idea
is combining our GMP compliant can you
mix prodigy instrument and tubing set
the highly flexible ACC software as well
as our Max GMP medium cytokines and
small molecules our clean works project
platform could support the entire
manufacturing process of adherent cell
types with this I'd like to introduce
some of the relevant applications that
we have developed on the clinics prodigy
adherence our cutter system
for you see related applications we have
developed Zeno free media for high
quality human proponent stem cell
expansion first we have the stem max IPS
proved reno-free media which is a very
cost effective research grade media in
this experiment two IPS clones were
expanded for twenty passages in the
media we found that sells at very stable
doubling times during long-term
cultivation using stem X IPS rule zero
free media human stem cells could be a
cultivated single cells or a cell
clusters meanwhile if we want to
translate into a clinical grade protocol
we will use the IPS prove GMP medium
which is the GMP compliant media
manufactured under iso 13485 the IPS
protein p medium is based on the same
formulation as the research rate medium
performance wise they give rise to very
similar results therefore you will have
a seamless transition from research
grade to GMP compliant Hume proponent
stem cell cultivation
G&P compliant you BAC manufacturing can
be realized in the prodigy ACC system by
using different modules this graphic
scheme gives you an overview of this ACC
based PSC expansion process and you can
find more detailed information
information such as consumables hands-on
timescale in a specific application
sheet
so let's first have a look at the
the proton stem cell expansion what you
see in these experiments is the
comparability study between the two
systems and what you can see is that
cells have a very similar phenotype so
over course of three passages they have
a very comparable immuno phenotype and
they keep the same differentiation pose
and potential as they have in the manual
system concerning the scales it's
worthwhile to mention what kind of
scales we have in the different formats
that we can provide we can amplify up to
5 times 10 to the 7 proponents stem
cells in the CCU in the chamber and up
to 2 times 10 to the 8 in a one layer
cell stack and this means that in the
five layer cell stack we can go up to
one to ten to the nine cells which is
for sure cell line dependent
next we were wondering if we can use the
clinic's project system to differentiate
proponent cells into specific cell types
for example midbrain dopaminergic
progenitors this project based
application has been supported by a
prestigious EU consortium neural stem
cell repair in which we have
collaborated with dr. Mallin Parma and
dr. Tokioka B in developing a G
compliant GMP complan protocol for PSC
to MSD a progenitor differentiation we
first adapted the protocol in our system
using our high quality cell culture
media cytokines and small molecules then
we transferred this manual
differentiation protocol to the clinics
prodigy system and developed an
automated differentiation protocol
including stringent QC and IPC
procedures again this is the process
overview and you can find more details
in the dedicated application sheet
we developed specific source otamatone
breasts to see panel which enables
determination of the correct identity
purity and potential to marriage NASA T
of the resulting mess da progenitors we
chose the positive mark as I F Fox a to
optics to a next one to identify the
ventral midbrain region of the floor
plate you see essays demonstrated that
prodigy based differentiation gives rise
to a high purity master a progenitor
population which was nearly no
contamination of residual reporting
cells and untargeted neural cell
populations rostral caudal patterning
was driven by increasing a kya 99201 the
concentration to also venture patterning
by increasing human sonic hedgehog
concentrations expression of pax6 is
indicative of a dose of phenotype
whereas MKX 6.1 and loss erotics to
expression are associated with a cordis
phenotype socks one identifies the
dorsal phenotype as well as primitive no
right to them
ki-67 was included to monitor the
proliferation capacity and oak tree
forest as a marker to identify the
residual proposed selves what you can
see by comparing it that we can clearly
identify the vent meant for midbrain
dopaminergic neurons and discriminant
them from dorsal for brain or ventral
hind brain states and that could arise
in an aberrant differentiation pathway
so next we compare how the different
systems corresponds so we compared to
manual differentiation procedure and the
clinic's prodigy basic differentiation
procedure and we found that both is very
comparable with more than 90 percent of
cellco expressing the key measures the
Select Opperman Erdrich progenitor
marker Oh takes two I up and foxy to
nearly no expression of pax6 Sox won and
opt for and decreased expression of Chi
67
so let's have
scalability starting from 1 million
proponent cells after five days pre
expansion and 16 days of differentiation
we can get roughly 4 billion high purity
Mesta a progenitor cells which translate
to almost 800 patient doses therefore we
can realize highly efficient and
scalable human proponent stem cell
differentiation in our clinics prodigy
system
so with this I'd like to shift to
another application which is the MSC
expansion so it's a very similar case
for human MSC manufacturing first we
have developed the research grade stem X
MSC expansion media and the MSC brute
GMP medium based on the same formulation
and with this we can now realize GMP
compliant and scaleable MSC expansion in
the closed and automated system
we also have a dedicated application
sheet for this application
what you can easily take from this slide
is that after 14 days of expansion
approximately 4 times 10 to the 8 M SES
can be harvested using the clinic's
prodigy system which is comparable to
men you're processing a flow cytometry
basic UCS a using our MSC phenotyping
kit was performed to confirm the quality
of the resulting MSC's houston MSC's met
ICD criteria showing high expression
levels of MSE specific markers see 73
t-90s MSE 105 and very low expression of
non MSC lineage markers the project
system could also be your time saver
especially at the DGC step all in all
the prodigy system can reduce the
hands-on time of the for MSC expansion
by roughly 70% so we can also realize
the isolation expansion and harvest of
MSC's in the automated and closed system
we've also extended this workflow to
various tissues including bone marrow
umbilical cord and adipose tissue in the
closed system we can now have as
clinically relevant numbers of emesis
with high purity from various tissues
within 20 days
you
so all in all we have the three major
applications and developed this is proof
on stem cell expansion mesta a
progenitor differentiation and MSE
expansion and this allows flexibility
for manufacturing of various and hiriam
cell types since this is not limited
disease cell types and lots more
protocols can be translated according to
the flexible software so in the last few
minutes I would like to share with you
our ideas how the clinics project system
can actually improve your cell
manufacturing and therefore I'd like to
highlight some key advantages of the of
the system so actually the system allows
a paralyzed cell manufacturing scheme
and simplify attractants fare and
increase user and product safety also it
reduces the requirements for cleanroom
and personnel which in the end means
cost reduction so reduce stands on time
and operator influence will also lead to
higher consistency the project system
has been provided in 31 countries
already and it gives us experience in
many different regulatory environments
the technology has been invested in by
many drug developers and cells gene
therapy companies over 25 trials are
underway using the chronic clinics
prodigy system worldwide in fact 20% of
our customers on more than one
instrument showing the strength of the
cleaner x project system for commercial
scale manufacturing the protocols and
data I just showed can also be found in
our application sheets and scientific
posters if you're interested we could
send more detailed information to you
with this I'd like to come to an end and
acknowledge our collaborators and also
our the projects that have been
generously funded by the EU and Germany
and also acknowledge all people have
contributed to the work and this I'd
also thank you for your attention and
like to take your questions after this
top
Thank You Sebastian and ciao for your
informative presentations we will now
start the Q&A portion of the webinar if
you have a question you'd like to ask
please do so now
just click on the ask a question box
located on the far left of your screen
we'll answer as many questions as we
have time for okay let's get started our
first question is is there a limit in
the number of media that one can use
over the course of PSP expansion and
differentiation
[Music]
actually in principle there is no limit
in the number of media that can be used
during expansion and differentiation
process using the accessories and that
is the connectors that the tube
extension etc our customers can always
connect additional media bags to the
tubing set and to fit their protocols
for instance in the ACC based masse a
progenitor differentiation workflow we
use four consecutive media first
eyepiece Bruijn P media then a neural
induction medium through proliferation
medium followed by a neural
differentiation William so actually you
could extend this even
right thank you your next question is
what are the scales of BSC and MSC enya
factoring in the clinic's prodigy
adherence cell culture system
um yeah using the system our customers
can perform scaled manufacturing of all
these cell types and I sort of briefly
mentioned in the presentation for the
purporting selves we can catch up to
five times ten to the seven cells within
the chamber then it's 200 million cells
in a one-layer cell stack and up to 1
billion cells in a five layer Sestak and
if you connect more subject to the
system the pluripotent stem cell
expansion scale will be even larger and
thus Animus are of course salon
dependent as I mentioned and different
lines may give rise to slightly
different results but this is actually
quite obvious for everyone working in
the field for the MS ES from two to
three five layer celtics that can be
used in parallel we can harvest roughly
200 million to 800 million MSC s roughly
within 20 days depending also on the
starting material from various tissues
that we can put in like bone marrow
umbilical cord adipose tissue and again
the semi mus also depend on the quality
and quantity of the starting material as
well as the expansion time
thank you your next question is do the
users need to operate the device under a
clean bench to ensure drilling no no no
as we pointed on the presentation The
Prodigy a CC based cell manufacturing
process is performed in a closed and GMP
compliant tubing set or in this external
culture vessel connected via closed
nasira welding for instance using a tea
room or welder and according to our
knowledge also the chronic cell stacks
are suitable for GMP manufacturing
therefore technically our customers can
perform GMP compliance a manufacturing
in a Class C room and there is no need
for a clean cell culture hood and yeah
so they get the Class C designation
actually derives from the European GMP
guidelines
this was actually correspond to a
100,000 according to the u.s.
designation or iso class 8
quite thank you your next question is
can you explain why the prodigy saves
time in comparison to manual production
yeah this is because the prodigy based
manufacturing is automated although user
interactions are still required but for
example in our ACC based MSC expansion
workflow the user can choose the density
gradient module to isolate mononuclear
cells from bone marrow aspirates and
this day a density gradient
centrifugation process fully automated
in the centric art unit this is a major
time saver for the entire workshop all
in all comparison to the menu based
expansion the system this stays roughly
70% of time and however I'd say reduced
manual interactions are there this means
that you have less user influenced and
higher reduce reproducibility and this
might even outweigh time-saving
considerations at this point
you
thank you we have one more question for
you as the prodigy system already been
used in any clinical studies or cell
therapy trials
yes actually the system has been widely
used for hematopoietic cells and more
recently for katisa based clinical
trials and currently according to a
large more than 25 trials are underway
using the clinics project system
worldwide also we've learned a lot from
cell therapies using hematopoietic stem
cells in cat hisses and will now if
you're ready to transfer this knowledge
to propone stem cell based therapies
thank you again Sebastian and ciao for
your time today and your important
research do you have any final comments
for our audience
thanks a lot for everyone to join us and
like I said in the beginning we really
wish that these technologies would help
you with your project and if you are
interested in our world climax prodigy
at here in cell culture system for
automated and GMP compliant stem cell
manufacturing please contact us or the
Milton e local office and we would like
to provide more information for you and
also live demos are also available on
demand
thanks a lot also for our host lab root
yeah this is a final remark from our
side
thank you we would also like to thank
levers and our sponsor Milton biotech
for underwriting today's educational
webcast
before we go I'd like to thank the
audience for joining us today and for
their interesting questions questions we
do not have time for today and those
submitted during the on-demand period
will be addressed by the speakers via
the contact information you provided at
the time of registration labret will
alert you via email when it's available
for replay we encourage you to share
that email with your colleagues who may
have missed today's live event until
next time goodbye